aux yeux de Kiev c'est un allié fiable
et majeur le Premier ministre
britannique richissounac à respecter
aujourd'hui une minute de silence en
hommage aux victimes du conflit le
Royaume-Uni qui poursuit ses efforts
pour aider l'Ukraine livraison de
matériel militaire formation des soldats
Ukrainiens la coopération entre les deux
pays bas son plein Hervé à Maury notre
correspondant nous attend à Londres
bonjour Hervé signe de cette entente
plusieurs cérémonies de soutien sont
organisés aujourd'hui au Royaume-Uni
racontez-nous
c'est commémoration ont commencé dès
hier par une veillée sur Trafalgar
Square aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit à 13h
heure de qui le Royaume-Uni a fait une
pause une minute de silence enfin dans
quelques heures un service religieux
aura lieu ici derrière moi devant la
statue de saint-volant de mer bien
entendu de nombreux crâniens sont
attendus pour se servir et communique
ensuite il y aura une marche vers
l'ambassade de rucher ou
ukrainien a tous qui les soutiennent
pourront manifester leur colère le roi
Charles a rendu hommage au très grand
courage au courage vraiment remarquable
dit-il dont les Ukrainiens ont fait
preuve et font preuve qu'il soit sur le
champ de bataille pour défendre la
liberté oui c'est même au Royaume-Uni ou
des dizaines de milliers sont réfugiés
pour élever leurs enfants loin des
bombes et des missiles pour finir je
tiens à citer un écrivain
ukrainien
la femme et les enfants sont
britanniques
André kurkhove que j'ai eu la chance et
l'honneur de rencontrer en mars dernier
en Ukraine estime que cette guerre c'est
le passé qui affronte l'avenir essayons
de supprimer l'indépendance
identité la culture
ukrainienne mais il ajoute que les
Ukrainiens ne baisseront pas les bras et
qu'ils croient on leur victoire le
président ukrainien veut le dire ce qui
était à Londres il y a deux semaines là
où vous vous trouvez donc visite pour
demander une nouvelle fois des armes aux
Occidentaux des ailes pour la victoire
des avions de combat et de l'armement
moderne tel était ces mots quelle est la
position aujourd'hui du gouvernement
britannique à ce sujet Hervé
aujourd'hui même le Premier ministre
britannique va s'adresser à ces
homologues du G7 les pays les plus
industrialisés au monde et les appeler à
accélérer leur effort pour armer
l'Ukraine c'est la position du
Royaume-Uni depuis le début de cette
invasion depuis
Boris Johnson avait exactement la même
position et ce n'est une position ici au
Royaume-Uni qui ne fait pas vraiment
débat le Premier ministre rachichouna a
reçu ce matin à Downing Street de
nombreux soldats d'Ukrainiens parmi eux
bien sûr ceux qui s'entraînent ici au
bâtiment des chars européens et char
d'assaut mais également qui sont formés
pour devenir pilote d'avion de l'OTAN en
ce qui concerne la livraison d'avions de
l'OTAN ce n'est pas pour tout de suite
dit le ben voilà le ministre britannique
de la Défense il considère que c'est du
long terme mais en revanche les
Ukrainiens ont besoin d'autres formes
d'armes de missiles de système
anti-aérien et de nombreux de nombreux
obus de canons notamment de 155 et tout
cela il encourage bien sûr tous ces le
Premier ministre comme le gouvernement
britannique encourage les autres membres
du G7 les Européens les Américains à
aller beaucoup plus vite bien sûr un
clin d'oeil aux Allemands merci Hervé
pour